are you looking forward to film tonight
what are you looking forward to I'm
looking forward to the visual sensation
that I know is going to happen it looks
so beautiful this film and obviously I'm
a big fan of Joe's and I'm very excited
to see this new magic adventure it's the
kind of thing you'd like to be working
on in the future it's got a period big
drama like this for sure yeah I'd love
to I'm what I want to give everything a
while but it would be great to go and be
in these kind of costumes again I
haven't done that in a while
and what are you working on right now I
just finished shooting a movie called
afternoon delight and I'm here shooting
Maleficent tell us a little bit about
each of those afternoon delight
I play a young stripper that makes very
very good friends with a woman who
brings her into our house and they have
large influences on each other I would
say and then Maleficent is kind of the
story of Sleeping Beauty but it's all
told through Maleficent's past and her
eyes and you're working on that it's
some boy listen that he and also
Angelina Jolie what's it like working
with those guys I haven't started
shooting yet I literally I've done
rehearsals but they are all very lot of
story very lovely people and I'm
incredibly excited and honored to be
working with them so what is it like
working on a kind of fairy tale and
bringing it up to date it's like a
childhood fantasy you kidding I playing
a fairy has been my friend since those
two years old and what can we expect
from your type of fairy you have to go
see the movie what my day would be like
to working on next you know I've read
some projects recently that I'm Rea
excited and would be interested honestly
I want to be challenged I guess and I'm
kind of Hoff I want to try everything
and dip my toes and everything and if it
goes wrong I just won't do it again
the direct that you say I really want to
work with them next um Paul Thomas
Hampson
I'd love to work with him I'd like to
work with Joe again a lot of people love
you to speak to you now good luck thank
you nice to meet you
have a good night
you